an autistic teenager in Arizona is
speaking out about a confrontation with
a police officer that left him with
multiple cuts and bruises
the 21 minute encounter was caught on
the officers body camera the cop tackled
the boy after mistaking his mannerisms
for signs of drug use Jamie yuccas spoke
with the teen and his mother she's at
the park in Buckeye that's outside
Phoenix where this incident occurred
Jamie good morning good morning the boy
was hurt when he and the officer fell in
this park now officers have been called
here in the past because of people doing
drugs and the officer himself is a drug
recognition expert but the boy's mother
said that if the officer understood just
one of the words her son said none of
this would have likely happened the
beach is in Hawaii in many ways Connor
libel is a typical fourteen-year-old boy
but what the officer who approached him
in July didn't know is that Connor is
also autistic what are you doing what
Connor was playing with string a form of
what's called stimming or self
stimulation that many autistic people do
to calm themselves what is that stop
walking away from me the officer mr.
Connors mannerisms for drug-related
behavior
Yaya ya know the situation escalated
quickly when you watch the video what
went through your mind it was really
hard to watch that
you know that's here that's my that's my
baby
the incident left Connor with multiple
cuts and bruises as well as an ankle
injury his mother says may need surgery
he pushed me down on the grass and then
he just hit me on the tree and he he
tackled me and then he didn't stop how
did that make you feel
I made me feel sad you still think about
it yes the Buckeye Police Department's
internal investigation cleared the
officer of wrongdoing finding there was
no excessive use of force and because of
his training as a drug recognition
expert they determined it was a
reasonable stop I hope that the family
sees that we will learn from this
incident and we are human and things are
constantly change involving changing
absolutely and it's it's almost
impossible to know and understand every
single little piece of every single
disorder they say nothing was wrong
nothing you know he didn't do anything
wrong but we're gonna make sure we
handle it differently why would you need
to handle it differently if everything
was done correctly the first time can
you set up all the way the Buckeye
Police Department says its officers are
trained to handle interactions with
people who have disabilities but they
are looking for ways to improve their
training procedures how do you feel
about police officers no a different
kind of Police Officer that makes me
feel happy a different kind yeah
different kind makes me feel happy but
the one police officer was mean to me
the sad the boy's family did send a
letter to the police department asking
for 3 things they'd like an apology from
the officer they'd also like the officer
to participate in an autism related
community service project and lastly
they'd like more training for all
officers in the department the Buckeye
Police Department says they did receive
that letter they have not responded yet
and don't know when and if they will
Nora alright Jamie thank you